what is your because I feel like you are
one of the when we think of like the
t-pains the acons the the guys who are
just like 50 cents the guys who can come
through with a hook always what is your
process when it comes to coming up with
a hook is it a punching thing do you lay
the melody first then you feeling the
lyrics like how you come up with hooks
first and foremost the hook is really
created it starts with me
um beat selection Beach listeners is
important and of course I'm punching
like but it's always off of field like
I've never went in the studio to make a
hit I just try to go in and make good
music I try to go in there and make a
song I would want to hear you know what
I mean and I try to put no limits on my
creativity you know what I'm saying so
I'm willing to go in there and try
things I'm willing to mess up and I've
spent a lot of hours in that studio so
I'm confident in what I do I'm confident
in what I say and I think confident
plays a big part in
yeah I think confidence and then
obviously you just gotta have that I
think your Melodies are so crazy like
you got to have a gift for coming over
those Melodies man oh I shout out to my
grandma put me on like that old school
music when I was little or he comes from
that Old Soul music like listen to The
Temptations uh who else received at The
Isley Brothers uh Kim right stuff like
that so it's not just all hip-hop like r
b too I like the oldies